with nations reenacting travel bans left
right and center and medical authorities
working around the clock to learn more
about the dangers of a new coveted
variant president joe biden today
addressed the public saying that the
strain is cause for concern but not for
panic according to the world health
organization the new strain omicron
poses a very high global risk we're
tracking this up to the minute and want
to now bring in dr purvy parikh she's an
allergist and immunologist at nyu
langone dr parikh it's good to speak
with you here on quick take president
biden said concern and not panic so
let's start with how concerned you are
about omicron
right you know so the variant is
concerning because this is the most
mutations that we've seen to date on
that spike protein which is what all of
our vaccines that we're using currently
target you know so it is concerning
but the reason why we're not panicking
yet is that we we don't yet know
is this something that's going to be
causing mild disease severe disease
our vaccines may still be very
efficacious against it so what this
actually means is we just need to use
those common sense precautions
especially as we move into those winter
months okay and you raise some very very
critical questions about the variant
that we still don't know the answer to
notably how quickly does it spread is it
capable of causing more serious disease
and
as you mentioned what's most important
here or top of mind for so many is will
it overwhelm the immunity that is
offered by existing vaccines and also
previous infections
how long will it take the
doctors the medical establishment to
find out the answers to these kinds of
questions is it something like days or
something like weeks
right well thanks to south africa we
were alerted quickly of this new variant
and now we've identified cases globally
but it will take at least two to three
weeks for us to test our current
vaccines
and for us to really see the full impact
is it just mild disease is it severe
disease does this increase
hospitalizations deaths transmission
remember all viruses have that
incubation period so it's not something
we can find out overnight
right right okay and of course omicron
was first detected in the southern part
of africa botswana and south africa
specifically earlier this month and it's
already been detected in more than a
dozen countries
since then including places like hong
kong which is a highly traveled region
although perhaps not as much recently
what is your confidence dr parikh that
the variant is or isn't in the united
states right now
right well realistically speaking i
think it likely is in the united states
especially in major cities like new york
which are gateways to the rest of the
world i think it's only a matter of time
before cases here are identified but we
already have
cases in north america and so i wouldn't
be surprised if it's already in the u.s
but that being said still the majority
overwhelming majority are from the delta
variant so
again that's why we're still urging
everyone please get vaccinated you know
this is your best bet to prevent any
infection and hopefully severe disease
and i'm glad you bring up delta does
that mean does the rise of omicron mean
that the delta variant is kind of in its
last legs or is it still raging
no not necessarily um you know the
majority of cases over 90 percent uh
even today yesterday are all delta
variant so uh absolutely those
vaccinations will not only help for
delta variant but remember uh that these
vaccines may still be very efficacious
even with omnicron so
um and we're seeing that these variants
are arising in places of the world where
vaccination rates are low in south
africa it's only around 24 25
so this further stresses the importance
of vaccinations to prevent future
variants and why we need to get vaccines
to everybody even our neighbors where
they may have lower rates yeah and it
really highlights the the differing
speed and timeline that we've been able
to roll out vaccines and even booster
shots between the rich world and the
developing world president biden urged
americans to get vaccinated or get their
booster shots does the emergence of
omicron change the booster timeline i
mean previously we were kind of
conditioned to think okay you get a
booster shot that'll probably be
something once every six months do we
now move to something like once every
three months
no i don't think it necessarily will
increase the frequency of the boosters
because we have great data um that even
six months eight months down the line
our current vaccines are efficacious in
preventing hospitalizations preventing
death severe disease so it's still very
very effective the boosters are just to
say proactive in case there is waning of
immunity in case there are new variants
so this doesn't necessarily mean we'll
need more boosters or more frequent
boosters but if you're due but please go
get one okay so that's what we know we
should do and then there's the actual
issue of what whether we will do any of
it because it's flu season it's also the
holiday season i've been in
conversations where people are talking
about how they're going to be doing a
lot of traveling there's going to be a
lot of get togethers i mean i've heard
people say that they don't have time
right now to go get a booster and risk
getting sick for the day afterwards that
they can really only do it after the
holidays and i know that this doesn't
make sense in the context of what we're
saying but talk about the timing of this
variant to emerge because middle of the
holidays middle flu season it's kind of
like a perfect storm
right absolutely what i would say is you
know make the time this should be an
absolute priority
the reason being is that any vaccine
needs at least two weeks to have its
full efficacy whether it be your flu
shot or your covid booster or even your
you know initial covert vaccination so
uh if you want to be protected for that
holiday season it's worth feeling run
down for maybe a day versus getting sick
or even worse ending up in the hospital
or with long-term complications
yeah even so though we have those
antibodies that have now been developed
i know they're super expensive but they
are effective do we have any sense of
whether these antibodies um are going to
be effective against a new variant as
well
yeah so that's another unanswered
question that hopefully we'll know in
the upcoming weeks um you know it looks
as if these antibodies should be helpful
with the variants but we don't know we
need to test it on individuals who do
get sick enough to require those
antibodies but again that's not
something that i would bank on even with
antibody treatments people still get
very ill people still need hospital care
or even have long covert or long-haul
consequences which you don't want you
know i see patients 18 19 months later
unable to function you know the your
best bet is preventing infection
altogether yeah taking the steps now the
u.s has already imposed travel
restrictions on eight nations in
south africa or the southern part of
africa does that mean
well i mean does it actually move the
needle because we've talked about how
there are other countries that are
outside of africa that have already seen
cases and it's been detected there and
so realistically as you mentioned it's
probably at some point in somewhere in
the united states so these all these
travel restrictions these travel bans
are now being imposed it's kind of after
the fact and it may make us feel better
but does it actually change anything
right that's a great question so what
we've found from a public health
standpoint is the travel bans don't
really help
they don't help curb spread if anything
it can make things even worse because
one people find their way against around
the travel bans people under report if
they're actually sick and unfortunately
then it punishes the countries that are
helping alert us quickly such as south
africa who
you know very correctly told us
immediately put us on alert for this
important variant so again by the time
you impose these bans it's already too
late it's already spread in that region
and likely elsewhere so and they are not
very effective
you know we're we're dealing with
omicron and it just occurred to me that
we're going to get through the greek
alphabet fairly quickly and we'll have
to go back to the top again and start
looking at the next version of beta
at what point does a virus stop mutating
um i mean i've heard from people that
mutations work so long as they find new
hosts and continue to spread but if they
kill off their
their patient then it's not a very
effective
mutation and so in order to stay
effective it needs to continue to spread
but not actually do so much damage that
the patient then can't transmit it to
someone else
correct you know you know it's in the
best interest of the virus to actually
weaken as it mutates because as you
correctly said then it can live on from
host to host and that's the idea
and possibly what we could be seeing
even with omicron because to date we've
only seen reports of milder cases so
fingers crossed that this isn't
something that turns into something that
causes severe disease deaths or
hospitalizations but believe it or not
the one thing that can help is again the
vaccinations because the milder
something is as it passes from person to
person and people who are vaccinated get
mild disease then you know it's even uh
more likely to quote-unquote burn out
sooner so that is the natural
progression of viruses and hopefully
will be happening soon uh with these
coven-19 variants okay that's that's a
piece of good news there so if omicron
continues to be something that um
spreads but may not actually do more
damage than just um come across as a bad
cold that may be an indication that the
virus is petering out and the mutations
are getting weaker and weaker which
would be a positive development but we
come we keep coming back to the need to
get vaccinated um the need to get
booster shots obviously some rich
countries the us included are rolling
out their booster shots other developing
countries are still trying to administer
their first shot of the two-step vaccine
so realistically how effective can the
us or israel the uk's approach really be
if there's a certain threshold of the
world's population that just isn't
vaccinated yet
right you know vaccine and equity is a
huge issue you know because as we've
seen for the last two years an outbreak
anywhere is an outbreak everywhere so um
yes boosters help they help slow the
spread especially as people in the us uk
israel are traveling so hopefully those
boosters will further help slow down the
spread but
we can't ignore the elephant in the room
which is getting every individual on
this planet vaccinated it's in our best
interest it's in their best interest so
really policies do need to focus on that
vaccine and equity otherwise we're going
to constantly have these moments of high
alert gotcha at what point would the
government or organizations be
advised to perhaps um cancel
in-person get-togethers there's a lot of
conferences coming up there are a lot of
events around the holidays that people
are organizing
what point should people think about
perhaps suspending all of that and not
going back into lockdown but choosing
the cautious route
right so you know that really depends on
your geographic region and that can
change you know moment to moment so it
all will depend on
how fast infection rates are rising in
the area where you live in addition to
resources being depleted so if again
hospitals start to become overwhelmed uh
healthcare workers resources are being
depleted you know faster than the need
of the patients in that area then we may
want to consider some of those
restrictions
but again you know i don't think a
universal lockdown is necessary because
every geographic region is different
colder areas might get hit harder
initially because we know viruses spread
more indoors versus outdoors so there's
so many factors to consider so again
it's very regional and geographic and
unique to your location got it dr purvi
parikh thank you so much for joining us
and giving us the latest on omicron dr
parikh is an allergist and immunologist
at nyu langone